(pages turning)
(somber piano music)
(woman groans)
- My bad.
- Here, you take--
- Yeah.
(men grunting)
(woman wails)
- Let me cut to the meat here.
I think you know
why we came over.
There seems to be a
little discrepancy
in the way we've been
interpreting the books.
- Listen, it's okay.
I mean, I've been
reading books for years,
and sometimes I still
read a book wrong.
- Well I think it's
clear that When Love Dies
is a nonfiction self-help book.
- I think it's clear that
you have brain problems!
- As a group, we're just
trying to figure out
what the mystery of
books is, you know?
What they all mean, learning
the patterns and stuff.
(woman cries)
(foreboding drum beats)
- Oh my god, you're
so depressed.
I, for one, am not gonna let
this minor tragedy ruin my day.
I'm just not.
Cuz I'm too strong for that.
- I know how to fix you.
Turn on the car lights.
How's everyone doing tonight?
- He's doing shtick.
- Classic!
- What do you call it when
Sabrina the Teenage Witch
makes a stink?
- I don't know, what?
What?
- Melissa Joan Fart.
(laughter)
(woman crying)
What do you call it when
Mel Gibson makes a stink
at the Jew Oscars?
- But uh, but, Gib, Gibson.
Mel Gibson, um...
- Brave Fart.
(laughter)
- That's so much better!
- Thank you very much.
- No way!
(raucous laughter)
(woman crying)
- I mean ching chong bing
bong but take a break.
- Oh, that was good.
That's good.
- I want you to scream.
- Why?
- Personally, I was
a little taken aback
by you storming off
in a cloud of anger
from our book club.
- I'm not angry.
- (chuckles) Yes, you are.
- No I'm not.
- Scream.
- Uh-Uh.
(laughter)
I'm not angry.
- Sure you are.
- No I'm not!
- How do you feel?
- A little bit better.
(screaming)
- Who do we got in the
backseat tonight, huh?
- Uh oh.
- It's you!
- Oh no, oh no!
- It's you, it's you!
- Hey buddy friend, where'd you
get your hair gel from, huh?
The fry basket out
of the french fries?
(laughter)
But seriously,
who's this fat piece of
shit in the backseat, huh?
- Me, he's doing
me, he's doing me!
- Lose some weight
and be a human.
(laughter)
- More, more!
- You are clinically retarded.
You need to wear a helmet
and shut the fuck up.
(laughter)
Paul Fart Mall Fart.
(screaming)
(ominous drum beats)
- Sweetie.
- Is everything okay?
- I'm sorry, I think so, baby.
- Well could you
just keep it down?
Cuz I'm actually Skyping
with Hillary Clinton.
- So are we.
- Well if you wouldn't
mind taking a break
from that boring ass shit,
I'd like to invite the
two of you to a funeral
for my child-dog.
- I'd kinda like
to get in on that.
Tremendous?
- We should get going.
Don't want to miss out
on that funeral fun.
(people cheering)
(tribal music)